le 16 décembre 2013
j'ai la tête dans la neige milieu de
l'antarctique et centaines de kilomètres
de là plus proche base scientifique mes
lunettes sont glacés m'empêche de voir
quoi que ce soit j'ai perdu mes gants
dans la neige en moins 40 degrés j'ai
une minute pour les retrouver avant que
mes droits de gel j'ai un mal de ventre
violences depuis quelques minutes
j'essaye de chercher des cachets contre
la douleur mais ils se sont répandus par
terre
j'essaye de serrer contre moi ma veste
pour me protéger contre un grand de 75
kilomètres par heure mon coéquipier dog
et à se remettre devant - il s'est pas
aperçu que je suis tombé il continue
dans la tempête
voilà déjà trois cents kilomètres qu'on
parcourt d'antarctique on à 250
kilomètres qui nous reste et me voilà
incapable de bouger
j'essaye de me lever mais je te rappelle
me tenir sur la cheville droite
j'ai une entorse j'ai une tendinite au
tendon d'achille alors je m'assois dans
la neige j'essaie de réfléchir un plan
tout en crachant du sang dans mon masque
l'ascension des derniers jours ont pas
rangé mon infection pulmonaire
mais c'est à ce moment là que je me
demande est ce que c'est trop pour moi
peut-être que j'ai atteint ma limite
peut-être que après trois expéditions au
pôle nord j'ai poussé mon corps à son
maximum
après tout je suis un truc dans cet
environnement est gamin de 19 ans un
étudiant
mais alors qu'est ce que j'ai fait dans
ce moment je me dis que peut-être la
réponse est qu'il faut abandonner
l'expédition
sinon quoi sinon il faut reprendre le
rythme de 12 heures de marche par jour
mais déjà en a ralenti on pouvait pas
tenir ce rythme on faisait 10 heures et
puis huit heures par jour mais à huit
heures par jour ça nous prend 35 jours
pour arriver au pôle sud
malheureusement on appris que avec nous
quatre semaines de provisions et de
réserves de gaz
je me souviens est difficilement des
moments qui est suivent m
d'hooghe a vu que j'étais plus avec lui
il est revenu me chercher il comprenait
pas ce que je faisais parterre enroulé
dans une couverture réfléchissantes que
normalement on utilise pour isoler le
sol de la tente
il a vu le téléphone sortie le sact
secours ouverts mais main ma peau
découvert c'était un désastre
alors ils attachent mon traîneau à sa
taille
il me tire vers lui et ensemble on
marche vers son traîneau qui l'avait
laissée à un kilomètre au sud
il n'a pas dit un mot
il n'avait pas besoin de parler pour que
je devine ce qu'il pensait on pouvait
pas continuer comme ça c'était en jeu
ses responsables mais alors ce soir
cette soirée je ne pouvais pas dormir
vous regardez le tissu de la tente au
dessus de moi que le vent soufflait avec
la force et c'est dans ce moment là que
je me suis demandé qu'est ce qu'on fait
au milieu de l'antarctique
mais pourquoi on marche péniblement jour
après jour dans l'environnement le plus
froid et plus monotone du monde
pourquoi est-ce que d'arguments on avait
passé deux heures par jour pendant deux
ans dans la salle de sport savais pas
mais pour nous un voulais comprendre un
peu mieux le problème du changement du
climat à travers d'un programme de
recherche scientifique mais on voulait
aussi engagé chacun les décideurs et
dirigeants
un jeune génération dans une
conversation plus constructif et le
timing de l'expédition n'aurait pas pu
être plus important parce que trois
semaines avant le début de l'expédition
des représentants de chaque pays se sont
rassemblées à varsovie pour continuer
les négociations pour un accord mondial
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et même si les décideurs qui
arrive à ce genre d'événements chaque
année on est meilleurs intentions et qui
donnent tout ce qu'ils ont le grand
public a plus ou moins perdu confiance
dans le processus
ça fait 23 ans qu'on négocie c'est plus
que mon âge
et pourtant on n'a pas traité mondial
et pendant que je réfléchissais à tout
ça dans la tente
il me manquait un lien au monde
extérieur
je me sentais complètement isolée au
milieu de l'antarctique alors en
cherchant du réconfort
j'ai retiré à une enveloppe de mon sac
de tentes avec des messages des mots
écrits par des proches message de ma vie
quotidienne il y avait un mot un
particulier qui a attiré mon attention
avant l'expédition j'avais travaillé
avec un kiné qui s'appelle john qui m'a
préparé à gérer les moments désagréables
de l'expédition
la douleur est distant à répétition on
avait travaillé ensemble il m'avait
envoyé un email une heure avant mon
départ qui me rappelaient des deux
stratégies sur lesquels on avait
travaillé ensemble la première stratégie
c'était de de se dire qu'on commence ici
oui l'expédition va être difficile on va
probablement avoir des blessures des
problèmes de santé
ça va être difficile mais ça sert à rien
de réfléchir de se concentrer sur le
patient
chaque matin il faut refaire les calculs
on se lève on se dit qu'est ce que je
vais faire aujourd'hui pour arriver
jusqu'au bout la deuxième stratégie
c'était de diviser l'expédition en
distance gérable alors à ce moment là on
était à 250 kilomètres du pôle sud on
sait jamais si on va pouvoir y aller
jusqu'au bout mais si on se contentait
affaires dit pas en avant si le possible
et ea d'ipad 2 - n'y aurait eu aucune
excuse et puis si si j'ai perdu mes
jambes
il me resterait les bras pour faire
c'est dit pas et c'est comme ça que
ensemble on a réussi à dépasser les
défis externes la douleur par exemple et
aussi les défis internes les jeux de
l'esprit
la frustration avec dog qui essayait de
minimiser les difficultés et quand on
rejetait la faute n'a sur l'autre alors
voilà comment on a réussi à atteindre le
pôle sud en 18 jours 4 heures et 43
minutes et comment on a battu le record
pour le plus rapide à des expéditions
non motorisés au post une le fait de se
concentrer ce que ce qui est important
nous a aidé à s'en sortir
aujourd'hui je me dis que ces petites
stratégies ne sont pas uniquement
valable pour un homme au front de
l'antarctique
elles sont peut-être aussi valable pour
un monde qui cherche à avancer se dire
qu'on commence ici au lieu de ressasser
le passé que on doit diviser le problème
en étapes surmontable sont autant de
clés qui doivent nous permettre à
construire ensemble le futur que nous
voulons au fond cette épreuve la plus
difficile que j'ai connu à ce jour de ma
vie m'a appris que lorsqu'il semble être
tard et qu'aucune solution existe
il est toujours possible d'agir merci